und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka gegen
abend und plötzlich ist sommer dieser
sonntag jedenfalls fühlte sich schon mal
so
die sonne lacht die bäume blühen wenn
nur das verdammte virus nicht wäre
immerhin die infektionszahlen gehen
runter impfzahlen hoch dürfen wir uns
also hoffnungen machen urlaubsreisen
biergärten grillabend mit mehr als einem
gast ein sommer wie er früher einmal war
darüber habe ich vor gut einer stunde
mit christian drosten ausführlich
gesprochen über dem sommer den herbst
die schulen und das bevor wir zu dem
interview kommen gibt es aber noch zwei
berichte über vorhersagen ein pandemie
zeiten und vorweg die vierte dominik les
meister impressionen aus einem sonnigen
deutschland das erste vorsichtige
lockerungsschritte wagt endlich raus
kommen corona hinter sich lassen wie
hier am timmendorfer strand an der
ostsee nutzen viele heute das gute
wetter man genießt habe ich schon so ein
bisschen normalität hier
das ist schon ganz gut also ich glaube
auch dass alle das brauchen
mit dem warmen wetter kommen noch
bessere corona zahlen bundesweit meldet
das rk ii 12 1656 neuinfektionen binnen
24 stunden das sind 3634 weniger als am
vergangenen sonntag
127 todesfälle kamen hinzu die
bundesweite sieben tage inzidenz sinkt
auf 118,6 die aussicht auf eine rückkehr
zur normalität ist so groß wie nie
impfen geht rasch voran also von daher
urlaubsplanungen werden möglich seit
heute gibt es zudem lockerungen für
geimpfte und genießen die sehnsucht nach
freiheit wächst und im moment senken die
instanzen ja sogar schneller als manche
erwartet hatten prompt wird die frage
gestellt ob die warnungen übertrieben
waren
wer is no glory in prevention sagen
wissenschaftler
das präventionsprojekt wenn die
warnungen die man aus sprach dazu führen
dass das schlimmste verhindert wird
heißt es im nachhinein schnell war doch
gar nicht so wild was habt ihr denn da
für schrecken an die wand gemalt
schreckensszenarien gab es einige aber
ja auch reale schrecken ärzteschaft und
pflegepersonal auf der intensivstation
denken sich das was sie dort auch jetzt
noch erleben nicht aus aber es wird
besser
es kommen spürbar weniger neue fälle
hinzu waren manche warnungen also nicht
doch übertrieben
damit hat sich christiane hübscher
befasst sie waren laut sie waren
drastisch sie waren vor allem
pessimistisch die warnungen vor der
dritten welle im laufe der nächsten
woche über die instanz und 200 werk
gehen
klar das können dann auch 100.000 pro
tag werden nach dieser prognose wann
sich die kunden der modellierer anschaut
dann wird man echt ein bisschen
schwermütig die virologin bringt man
prognostiziert im februar der wettlauf
ist längst verloren es wird kommen wie
in england
der chef der intensivmediziner droht im
märz mit einem bergamo in deutschland am
ende kommt es glücklicherweise so
dramatisch nicht erklärungsversuche es
ist richtig dass unsere vorhersage ende
märz war das wir 607000 ein schlechtes
fall sogar 8000 intensivpatienten zu
erwarten gewesen waren und dass es nicht
eingetroffen worüber wir sehr froh sind
warum ist das so wir vermuten dass das
sehr viel mit den osterferien zu tun hat
karl lauterbach warnt mitte april für
die nächsten sechs wochen vor über
10.000 toten
er irrt panikmache die er heute bereut
man das bei euch nicht denn die
warnungen beschreiben was passiert
werden wir nicht gegensteuern
das ist es ganz klassisch schicksal
eines vorbeuge mediziner ist ja
mittlerweile erlebt dass man dann in der
öffentliche berichterstattung sehr breit
stattfindet wenn man apokalyptischen
zahlen in die welt setzt eine
gesellschaft fixiert auf den worst case
fall besser wäre sich immer das ganze
bild machen denn in jedem seriösen
modell stecken verschiedene szenarien
das problem was denke ich immer mal
passiert ist dass gerade die
pessimistischen modelle aufgegriffen
werden wir als modell ihrer wir
versuchen typischerweise nicht ein
zukunftsszenario zu machen folgen für
einen solchen langen zeitraum sondern
mehrere
und dann schauen wir was unter den
bedingungen dass es besonders schlecht
läuft oder dass es besonders gut läuft
passieren könnte viel mehr können wir
nicht machen weil das verhalten der
menschen bei dem fortschritt und andere
faktoren sich ja immer wieder ändern
die politik aber muss mit unsicheren
modellen in der krise einschränkende
maßnahmen begründen bis hin zur bundes
notbremse politische beobachter warnen
wenn immer nur alarm schreien riskiere
auf die dauer glaubwürdigkeit nicht nur
den tunnel all diese
katastrophenszenarien das hat sich
abgenutzt und je öfter wir das machen
umso weniger bleibt tatsächlich an
glauben und diese voraussagen übrig
tatsächlich war für die modellierer der
impfeffekt in den letzten wochen schwer
zu berechnen
genau wie der saisonalen effekt weil der
frühling lange auf sich warten ließ
erstaunlich aber auch das
robert-koch-institut ging wegen der
mutationen offenbar von einem sich immer
fortsetzen den exponentiellen wachstum
aus prognostiziert zu ostern mehr fälle
als an weihnachten und kalkuliert nicht
ein dass menschen ihr verhalten ändern
wenn man keine massnahmen eingezogen
hätte dann wäre diese prognose auch
eingetreten
wir haben ja gesehen zum beispiel das
über ostern deutlich weniger mobilität
stattgefunden hat als wir das gedacht
hätten und damit erklären wir dass die
leute
diese gefahr erkannt haben prognosen
bleiben nur eine gefahrenabschätzung nur
wenn sie differenzierter kommuniziert
werden können sie helfen auch im zweiten
sommer der pandemie wo stehen wir im
moment mit der korona pandemie darüber
wann wir mit einem mann sprechen die man
eigentlich gar nicht mehr vorstellen
muss ich tu's trotzdem professor
christian drosten von der leiter der
virologie in der berliner charité guten
abendessen guten namen frau slomka
die frage die allen auf den nägeln
brennt ist wie wird der sommer was sagt
der virologe
der sommer kann ganz gut werden in
deutschland ich denke dass wir zum juni
hin erstmalig wirklich effekte sehen die
der impfung zuzuschreiben sind
wir wissen nicht ganz genau ob das was
wir jetzt sehen in dieser entspannung
auch schon ein bisschen von der impfung
mitbestimmt wird wahrscheinlich nicht
wahrscheinlich ist das einfach
verhaltens bewusstsein der bevölkerung
die leute machen eben schon gut mit weil
sie schon viel verstanden haben darüber
auch und wir müssen jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen aufpassen dass wir nicht zu
früh ein totale euphorie verfallen denn
wir sind einfach noch nicht so weit wie
andere länder beispielsweise in england
wo man sehr daten basiert sehr
wissenschaftsbasierte entscheidet und wo
man durchaus jetzt schon über 50 prozent
bei der gesamtbevölkerung ist mit der
impfung wenn man das auch die
erwachsenen rechnen denn die kinder
werden ja auch dort nicht geimpft im
moment liegt dass über 60 prozent und da
kann man tatsächlich schon solche schutz
effekte durch die impfung erwarten also
sie meinen so 60% zumindestens
erstimpfung bräuchte man schon also ein
paar wochen sollte man jetzt noch
vorsichtig sein oder was wir jetzt so
ihr ratschlag ja wir sind da in
deutschland einfach noch nicht also wir
haben ja in deutschland so um die 32
prozent erstimpfungen bei den zweit
impfungen hängen wir vielen weiter noch
hinterher wir sind noch nicht bei zehn
prozent vollständig kämpfen
und man braucht einfach ein gewisses
niveau und keiner weiß ganz genau wie
hoch dieses niveau liegt also diese
einfach gerechnete zahl von 70 prozent
die sind auf 80 prozent erhöht wird das
ist unter perfekten laborbedingungen zu
sehen wir wissen nicht in einer
natürlichen bevölkerung wo das virus ja
ein haufen auftritt die wieder
miteinander
verbunden sein müssen diese netzwerke
die werden auch schon durchbrochen wenn
überträger geimpft sind in kleinerer
zahlen dann hatten sie im januar noch
gewarnt wenn man jetzt auf macht sobald
die risikogruppen und vor allem die
alten menschen durch geben dann werden
die zahlen furchtbar hochschießen also
das waren auch monströse aussichten
dies ergab haben wir sie da auch zu sehr
schwarz gesehen oder hatten sie das
nicht damit gerechnet dass es dann doch
nochmal lockdown geben würde
ja genau also bei mir war es eher so das
war jetzt eine seiner zusammensetzung
aus dem was modellierer mir sagen ich
bin ja selber kein modell ihrer und dem
was ich eigentlich erwartet hatte so in
anbetracht dass damals im januar
erwarteten im fortschritt also damals
sollte bis ostern im prinzip die kurorte
ab 80 aufwärts vollkommen geimpft sein
und die siebziger aufwärts die sollten
auch schon geimpft sein und dann kommt
ostern dazu und dann hatte ich gedacht
na ja also zu der zeit wird dann
wahrscheinlich auch in der politik auch
in der rechtsprechung und so weiter der
reflex kommen dass jetzt die begründung
für die beschränkungen weniger
durchgreifend ist und dass man jetzt
einfach locker muss und dass wir aber
bis zu dieser zeit noch nicht in den
dann ungeschützten jüngeren
bevölkerungsteilen überhaupt einen
schutz haben jetzt hat sich natürlich
durch die änderungen bei astra und so
weiter die im verteilung stark geändert
und wir kommen da glaube ich jetzt in
weitere effekte rein das ist nicht mehr
so eine steil abfallende flanke in den
altersgruppen
das heißt sie wären jetzt mal um so ganz
pragmatisch zu sagen optimistisch dass
urlaubsreisen biergärten und vielleicht
auch mal grillen mit mehr als einer
externen person im sommer im juli/august
möglich sein werden ja davon gehe ich
aus also dass man gerade im außenbereich
natürlich wieder vieles zu lassen kann
wir werden dann da sein wo eben die
engländer jetzt sind also wir haben in
england doch eine beträchtliche
impfquote inzwischen und dort ist es so
draußen kann man sich mit zwei
haushalten treffen das führt aber auch
dazu dass außengastronomie wieder
möglich ist und das hat man in england
richtig gemacht und
es hat ja dort auch genießen das ist
irreversibel das geht nur noch in eine
richtung wir werden uns da nicht wieder
täuschen lassen und müssen wieder zurück
in den lock down und darum sind wir ein
bisschen vorsichtiger und wir müssen
eben länger warten weil wir noch nicht
so weit sind mit unserem fortschritt
aber wir fragen uns natürlich kommt
nochmal eine tabelle also werden wir im
herbst anstehen
der herbst ist eine andere überlegung
also im herbst sind wir dann in
deutschland so dass große teile der
erwachsenen bevölkerung geimpft sind
dann kommt ja zunächst mal diese idee
mit der herdenimmunität ich glaube man
muss dazu mal sagen eine herdenimmunität
heißt ja nur dass dieses unkontrollierte
verbreiten nicht mehr zustande kommt
also wenn man nichts tut dann
explodierte
das wird dann nicht mehr passieren aber
das heißt nicht dass die krankheit sich
gar nicht mehr überträgt oder ganz
verschwunden ist das heißt es wird immer
noch leute geben in der bevölkerung die
sie nicht geimpft und die haben volles
risiko sich zu infizieren und die werden
sich zum herbst hin natürlich auch noch
ein zweites und drittes mal gedanken
darüber machen und sich dann hoffentlich
nachimpfen lassen denn wir brauchen bei
den erwachsenen eine sehr hohe impfquote
gegen dieses virus wir werden ja
hoffentlich dann die kinder von 12
aufwärts auch impfen aber die jüngeren
kinder werden wir dann nicht im kasten
bedeutet dass wir die kinder unter zwölf
jahren
na ja also das wissen wir im moment
nicht ganz genau
also erstmal finde ich es sehr gut dass
es so kommt dass wir also jetzt die über
zwölf jahren kinder tatsächlich impfen
können das so gut läuft mit den
impfstoffen bei den jüngeren kindern ist
es eben so
es müssen jetzt studien gemacht werden
die laufen auch schon die haben ihre
spezialitäten also die sind die muss man
nicht so ganz großer fallzahl anlegen
aber man muss eine dosis finden also
diese dinge die machen das noch ein
bisschen schwieriger
sicherheitsüberlegungen sind dann
natürlich auch dabei die ganz genau
befolgt werden müssen
deswegen bin ich nicht so sicher ob man
tatsächlich so schnell die kleineren
kinder impfen kann und man muss da jetzt
natürlich überlegen was passiert also
ein beispiel dass wir gut an führen
können dass so ein sehr gutes
denkmodelle es ist wieder england dort
haben wir viele erwachsene viele eltern
jetzt geimpft
und wir sehen erstaunlicherweise nachdem
jetzt einen monat oder in einigen teilen
sogar noch länger die schulen offen sind
mit testbetrieb zweimal wöchentlich
abstrich und testung also wirklich
strenge regeln aber ein offener
schulbetrieb die zahlen in den schulen
kommen jetzt nicht hoch und das ist ganz
anders als im dezember wo wir vier fünf
mal so hoch
in der intelligenz lagen wie bei den
erwachsenen weil die erwachsenen eben
geimpften dadurch sind auch die kinder
besser geschützt oder tragen nicht so
viel während in die schulen rein dann
gibt es ja auch leute die sagen die
kinder von uns jetzt eigentlich auch
nicht so sorgen machen die werden doch
eh nicht so schwer krank oder merken
sogar gar nichts von der korona
infektion ja das hat einige berechtigung
man muss aber zwei gedanken glaube ich
noch mal überlegen und dagegenhalten der
eine gedanke ist wir wissen nicht ganz
genau ob so ein so eine abschirmung
durch die erwachsenen also das virus ist
in einer schule und dann gibt es ein
ping pong effekt mit den amt mit in
haushalten das scheint sich jetzt in
england im moment glücklicherweise nicht
einzustellen das ist gut wir wissen aber
nicht ob das noch so ist im herbst wenn
die erwachsenen ihre impfung schon über
ein halbes jahr hinter sich haben und
der schutz durch die impfung dann etwas
schlechter wird nicht gegen die schwere
krankheit bei den erwachsenen sollen
gegen die weitergabe des virus an die
kinder das ist der eine gedanke der
andere gedanke ist es gibt ja neben der
akuten symptomatik noch diese multi
system informations erkrankung also eine
immunologische mit getriebene erkrankung
nach der phase 2 infektionen von acht
neun wochen danach bei kindern genau so
ja vielleicht von vom grundschulalter
bis zur pubertät das ist so das
zeitfenster wurde das auftritt und es
gibt einige daten die lassen vermuten
dass die häufigkeit dieser schweren
erkrankung im bereich von 1 2000 liegen
könnte und das ist natürlich viel zu
viel wenn das so sein sollte wenn sich
das erhärtet dann muss man in meiner
vorstellung auch die jüngeren kinder
impfen oder muss tatsächlich noch mal
sehr starke kontrollmaßnahmen im
schulbetrieb haben bei den jüngeren
schülern im winter rüsten sich neben von
dem gespräch mit also für den sommer
sind sie eigentlich auch zu
sichtlich im herbst müssen wir ein
bisschen aufpassen für alle den genug
geimpft haben und auf die kinder vor
allem auf die kleinen kinder muss man
ein auge haben so sieht es für mich aus
ja danke für das gespräch sehr gerne und
jetzt macht erstmal heinz weiter mit
anderen nachrichten von diesem sonntag
eine konferenz zur zukunft europas ist
heute in straßburg offiziell eröffnet
worden
vorgesehen ist dabei auch eine starke
bürgerbeteiligung zum auftakt
verteidigte frankreichs präsident marco
die europäische demokratie mahnte aber
auch reformen an
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
sagte die konferenz sei eine echte
chance um europäer zusammen zu bringen
und eine gemeinsame vision von der
zukunft zu entwickeln
in rund einem jahr sollen dann konkrete
reformvorschläge vorlegen
russland hat mit einer großen
militärparade an den sieg über
nazi-deutschland vor 76 jahren erinnert
in moskau marschierten etwa 12.000
soldaten über den roten platz gedacht
wird auch der 27 millionen kriegstoten
der damaligen sowjetunion präsident
putin verfolgte die parade gemeinsam mit
weltkriegsveteranen in einer rede
versprach er die nationalen interessen
zu verteidigen und den schutz vor
angriffen von außen nach dem wahlerfolg
der schottischen nationalpartei hat beim
minister johnson deren vorsitzende des
deutschen und die spitzen der anderen
landesteile zu einem krisengipfel
eingeladen
es soll dabei um die gemeinsamen
herausforderungen und die weitere
zusammenarbeit gehen die schottische
regierungschef ins deutschen machte
derweil deutlich dass sie in dem
wahlergebnis auch ein votum für eine
neue volksabstimmung über die
unabhängigkeit von großbritannien sieht
in jerusalem reist die gewalt nicht ab
die zweite nacht in folge kam es an
mehreren orten zu straßenschlachten
zwischen palästinensern und der
israelischen polizei auch am tempelberg
im laufe des wochenendes wurden hunderte
menschen verletzt
seit tagen kommt es immer wieder zu
protesten und mahnwachen bei dem ostteil
der stadt mehreren palästinensischen
familien die zwangsräumung droht nach
dem anschlag auf eine schule in
afghanistans hauptstadt kabul ist die
zahl der opfer auf mindestens 50
gestiegen
darunter sind größtenteils junge mädchen
sie waren auf dem weg nach hause als
drei sprengsätze explodierten
wer dahintersteckt ist weiter unklar im
land wächst die angst vor einer neuen
welle islamistischen terrors besonders
angesichts des anlaufenden
internationalen truppen abzug noch
viereinhalb monate bis zur
bundestagswahl
wie geht es den drei parteien die
zumindest so hoffnungsvoll sind dass sie
einen eigenen kanzlerkandidaten
beziehungsweise kandidatinnen geführt
haben die cdu ist gerade noch in der
post entscheidungsphase in der man sich
fragt ob man sich tatsächlich richtig
entschieden hat
die grünen haben zwar ihre k-frage laut
losgelöst und auch sonst größtmögliche
harmonie verbreitet die allerdings
gerade von boris palmer gestört wird und
nicht jetzt der spd die ja eigentlich
ein abonnement auf parteiinterne
konflikte hat im letzten zdf
politbarometer kam sie auf nur 14
prozent das könnte panik auslösen
selbstzweifel und ärger tut es aber
anscheinend nicht wenn man ihren
sonderparteitag heute verfolgte von
rechenberg berichtet es ist der
parteitag des urlaubs stolz auf ihn
zugeschnitten auf ihn zulaufen
der kanzlerkandidat startet die
aufholjagd er muss ich möchte eine
regierung anführen die unser land nach
vorne bringt eine regierung die sich
etwas vornimmt
die ideen umsetzt statt zu zaudern
zögern zu verbessern und zu verhindern
die schwächen der anderen ein pfeiler
der wahlkampfstrategie die grünen
versprechen mehr als sie halten könnten
die union habe statt eines plans affären
früher hieß es bei den konservativen ja
immer wir stehen für maß und mitte heute
stehen sie für maßen und masten schuh
zupackender wird's nicht scholz weiß den
beißer nimmt ihm keiner ab
gentleman angriff fast besser zu ihm und
zur wahlkampf botschaft eine
gesellschaft des respekt das heißt
niemand sieht verächtlich auf andere
herab weil er oder sie sich für stärker
hält für reiche oder gebildete für
besonders aufgeklärt oder besonders
problembewusst scholz redet über
mindestlohn klimaneutralität kindergeld
mehr als 600 delegierte lauschen
skeptisch eigentlich wegen schlechter
umfragewerte eigentlich man glaubt ihm
und ich glaube ich das ist seine kunden
dem er wuchern kann er erst unaufgeregt
ehrlich entschlossen das ist ein macher
und der hält was er verspricht und hebt
nicht ab sondern bleibt bei den menschen
mehr die kernfragen wie er formuliert
hat also auch gleich nachher erklärt und
das war ich schon von mobilität klima
digitales gesundheit der kern des spd
zukunftsprogramms dass die partei heute
auch verabschiedet fast einstimmig man
könnte auch sagen ohne gegenwehr
die dicken brocken hatte man im vorfeld
abgeräumt leise zehn monate ließ sich
die partei dafür zeit
bloß kein streit heute es ist ganz
deutlich dass olaf scholz tatsächlich
auch versucht beides miteinander zu
verbinden seine person und das programm
das hat er meines erachtens sehr
überzeugend gemacht dass er sagt diese
vier missionen der spd für die stünde er
und er sei auch derjenige der einerseits
die erfahrung hat und andererseits weiß
dass es nicht nur um ziele geht sondern
auch um deren umsetzung und so
bestätigte dieser erste volldigitale
spd-parteitag scholz als
kanzlerkandidaten mit mehr als 96
prozent
ein vorschuss für die aufholjagd ab
jetzt muss chance liefern
und nochmal heinz mit dem sport an
diesem wochenende und dazu erst zur
fußball bundesliga heute gab es drei
spiele mit diesen ergebnissen erster fc
köln sc freiburg 1 zu 4
frankfurt mainz 1 2 1 und hertha bsc
arminia bielefeld 0 0
die deutsche nummer eins im tennis
alexander zverev hat zum zweiten mal das
masters finale von madrid gewonnen
in einem umkämpften match setzte sich
der 24-jährige in drei sätzen 6 7 6 4
und 6 2 gegen den italiener matteo
contini durch nach verlust des ersten
satzes sind tie break konnte der
hamburger das spiel noch drehen und
verwandelte nach 2 stunden und 40
minuten den zweiten matchball
zuvor hatte er bereits gegen die
turnierfavoriten rafael nadal und us
open sieger dominik team gewonnen
es ist der vierte meistertitel seiner
karriere
lewis hamilton hat den formel 1 grand
prix von spanien in barcelona gewonnen
formaxx verstappen und valtteri bottas
hamilton baut damit in der gesamtwertung
seinen vorsprung vor verstappen weiter
aus jubel in der kommando box die
mercedes zwei stopp strategie ist voll
aufgegangen sechs runden vor schluss
überholte lewis hamilton seinen
härtesten wm-rivalen max verstappen von
red bull dessen reifen hatten nach nur
einem stopp zu stark abgebaut so
vergrößert lewis hamilton seine
gesamtführung in der wm wertung ab 14
punkte
die deutschen piloten verfahren auf
ihren startpositionen sebastian vettel
im ersten martin auf 13 mit schumacher
auf 18 im harz sophie scholl wäre heute
100 jahre alt geworden hätte sie ihren
24 geburtstag erlebt hätte sie ihn am
tag nach der befreiung gefeiert sie
hatte die kapitulation am 8
das ende des krieges das ende der
naziherrschaft erlebt
doch da war sie schon mehr als zwei
jahre tot eine so junge frau brutal
hingerichtet weil sie es gewagt hatte
flugblätter zu verteilen was würde
sophie scholl wohl dazu sagen dass er
eine ikone geworden ist und würde sie
sich im grabe umdrehen wenn sie wüsste
wer sich so alles heutzutage auf sie
beruft
umso wichtiger nicht zu vergessen wer
sie war
wogegen sie kämpfte und wer sie ermordet
daran erinnert christhard läpple 18
februar 1943 zwei wochen nach stalingrad
sophie und hans scholl verteilen in der
münchner uni das sechste flugblatt der
weißen rose als sophie die flugblätter
von der galerie in den lichthof schubst
schlägt der hausmeister alarm
diese bilder haben sich in unser
gedächtnis eingebrannt widerstand ist
möglich aber dieser mut kann das leben
kosten
geben sie doch endlich so dass sie mit
ihrem bruder zusammen die flugblätter
und verteilt haben
ja ich bin stolz darauf
sophie scholl mit glückliche kindheit im
schwäbischen forchtenberg war kein
mythos
sie war ein mensch lebenslustig und
idealistisch aber auch kompliziert und
selbstquälerischen 1932 zieht die
siebenköpfige familie scholl nach ulm
soviel liebt die natur spielt bach und
liest rilke gedichte ein selbstbewusstes
mädchen mit frechen kurzhaarschnitt und
einem großen herzen
schwankend zwischen lust und traurigkeit
als hitler an die macht kommt ist sophie
12 mit leib und seele schließt sich die
schülerinnen der hitlerjugend an
aufrichtigkeit und gemeinschaft sind ihr
wichtig wie ein feuriger wilder junge
steigt sie im bund deutscher mädel bdm
bis zur gruppenführerin auf sie war so
erzählten es klassenkameradin noch 1937
mit 16 jahren 150 prozentige
nationalsozialisten vor der sie angst
gehabt hätten
die klassenkameraden vom hitler mädchen
zur weißen rose geht sowie einen
siebenjährigen am ende konsequenten weg
1942 die wände in münchen die 21 jährige
studentin ist vom freundeskreis ihres
bruders hans fasziniert die wird über
freiheit gestritten
in zeiten die in eigenständiges denken
lebensgefährlich ist
sie ist eine frau die ja keinen
kompromiss einfach mehr machen konnte
natürlich gab es momente der angst auch
in dieser zeit aber ich glaube ihre
vorstellung dass sie das richtige getan
hat und auch ich glaube hat sie durch
diese hindurch getragen so viel typ
texte organisiert geld und
vervielfältigung geräte am 25 januar 43
verteilt sie in augsburg 2000
flugblätter auf denen steht zerreißt den
mantel der gleichgültigkeit entscheidet
euch gehe es zu spät ist
warum fragte vernehmer das gesetz ändert
sich das gewissen nicht
so ein herrlicher sonniger tag sagt
sowie noch und ich muss gehen
keine vier stunden nach dem urteil wird
sie wegen hochverrats enthauptet sophies
leben war kurz aber ihre mutige tat wird
umso länger
und mit der frage wie aus einer
krisenhaften demokratie eine apokalypse
mit krieg und völkermord entstehen
konnte haben sich auch die kollegen von
zdfinfo ausführlich beschäftigt die
zehnteilige doku reihe krieg und
holocaust der deutsche abgrund finden
sie in der zdf mediathek in der rubrik
dokumentationen und jetzt zu guter letzt
unser sonntäglicher blick auf die
nächste woche heute von einer klasse von
hamburg bis konstanz werden am montag
regenbogenfahnen am kirchenweg in über
70 gemeinden werden sich homosexuelle
paare öffentlich segnen lassen können
gegen den willen des vatikans die
initiative liebe gewinnt will ein
zeichen setzen gegen die in ihren augen
veraltetes sexualmoral der katholischen
kirche
während christen am donnerstag christi
himmelfahrt begehen werden werden
muslime weltweit das zuckerfest feiern
nach 30 tagen wird der fastenmonat
ramadan zu ende sein
große festessen verwandtenbesuche und
gemeinschaftliche gebete in der moschee
werden aber auch in diesem jahr pandemie
bedingt nicht uneingeschränkt
stattfinden können
am freitag wird die fdp in berlin ihr
programm für die bundestagswahl
beschließen
beim digitalen bundesparteitag werden
zudem die spitzenkandidatinnen und der
vorstand gewählt die ankündigung neuer
nutzungsbedingungen bei whatsapp hatte
im januar heftige proteste ausgelöst und
den start verschoben am samstag werden
sie nun in kraft treten nutzer innen
müssen zustimmen und dem mutterkonzern
facebook erlauben daten zu teilen viele
wechselten deshalb zu anderen messen
germany telegramm oder signal und noch
der ausblick aufs wetter morgen im osten
viel sonne sonst wechselnd bewölkt und
zunächst nur vereinzelt schauer am
nachmittag im südwesten kräftiger regen
im norden einzelne gewitter höchstwerte
17 bis 30 grad
die weiteren aussichten am dienstag im
osten noch länger sonnig und bis zu 28
grad warm im westen schon deutlich
kühler und häufig regen ab mittwoch
überall wechselhaft mit schauern und
gewittern
bei nur noch 12 bis 21 grad das war von
uns es folgt der sonntagskrimi und um
0.25 gibt es dann die nächste hotels
presse- und welche nächste heute-journal
woche führen sie hier claus kleber und
gundula gause auf wiedersehen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]